-Thank you, Judy.
Such a warm welcome makes
me feel like such a fraud,
but I know I am, as
many of you are, so
lucky to be at the
Radcliffe this year.
And I thank Dean
Liz Cohen, Judy,
and the smartness
of the reviewers
in getting us all here.
But I recognize it to
be an academic idyll,
which most of the
universities that we come from
are no longer, and so I want
to talk about neoliberalism
to some extent and
how wonder works
with the neoliberal worlds.
Many of you heard in
my introductory story
last week-- I spoke about
how I started the origin
story for this work,
when I literally
stumbled over four priests
trying to physically push
a cow into a mirrored
luxury elevator.
And I wondered why, and I was
told that the ritual would
be wonderful, which it was.
And so I stumbled
serendipitously
into this project of thinking
about wonder, and as Judy said,
it's taken me an enormously
long time-- 16 years.
But it grew out of two
very simple questions.
The first one was scholarly,
and the second one was personal.
We'll start with the scholarly.
Can anyone tell the encompassing
story of a radically diverse,
ancient society like
India that's propelled,
pushed into the modern moment
through recording fragments
of creative enterprise?
And can one design a good
life-- a personal question--
in a neoliberal context?
The two questions
might seem divergent,
and indeed I'd consider
them very divergent.
But they've come
to a focus, and I
hope I'll elucidate this
focus as I go forward.
When I speak of
neoliberalism, I'm
using it in the
simplest sense-- what
Jean and John Comaroff
here at Harvard
called "millennial capitalism"
and the radical sort
of uncertainty and precarity
it brings to our lives.
So I turned to my hometown
of Bangalore for answers,
and Bangalore is acknowledged
to be, as Judy told you,
the Silicon Valley of Asia.
It is the center for biotech,
for information technology.
It is a center for innovation.
And at one point in
2007, it was supposed
to be the fastest
growing city in Asia.
And to just give
you a sense, in 1990
when I left to go to school--
I think of it as a town,
forgive me-- it was
2.9 million people.
I went to Denmark to
speak, and they reared back
when I said a "town"
of 2.9 million people.
But in 2010, the
latest census we have,
we had an estimate of 9.2,
and that is just an estimate
of families that were counted.
There are many people living in
precarious slum circumstances
that are not counted
in the census.
So you can see the
radical shift in 20 years.
I'm going to come back
to Socrates in a minute.
So that's typical Bangalore.
And as you can see,
it's centrally located
in the subcontinent of India.
It's an exciting
cosmopolitan city.
It's a hub of disruptive
innovation or creativity,
of building and patenting
new technologies.
The Fortune 500 companies
there are largely
software-based companies, IT
companies, biotech companies.
It's supposedly known for
curating new ideas, objects.
People think of it as an icon
of smokeless kind of growth.
So I thought, surely, the
bourgeoisie of Bangalore
would be able to tell me
something about a good life
and how to live it, right?
Surely, they grasped at
what a good life would be.
At the top of this building is
the fanciest bar in Bangalore,
and the cover charge is $700.
That's before you
start drinking.
I began study in February
1998, and in the 17 short years
since then, neoliberal
policies have
affected the city spectacularly,
increasing growth,
as I mentioned.
It moved from being
a safe green city
that I grew up in
to a city where
water shortages, rolling
blackouts, extreme poverty
and inequality, cutting
of the green cover,
desertification-- all that
was happening simultaneously
as I was doing the study.
This was one of the main
streets in 1967, I believe,
and this is the
same street today.
So the anthropological
proposition that follows
is very simple.
It's modest.
It's in three parts.
And in this talk,
I'm going to take
a slice of a slice
of a larger question,
and I'm going to deal
with technology here.
But the larger anthropological
proposition about wonder
is as follows.
Can we try to make it visible?
Can we "f" the
ineffability of wonder?
Can we think of an
invitation to wonder
as a strategic yet passionate
act that can be hosted,
built, captured, and stoked?
And can we explore this
sort of experimental ethos
within which wonder is created?
And can we think about
creativity differently?
And what are the ethics of
a creative, contingent act?
So I'm going to try and
work my way around these.
I probably won't
get all of them,
but let's see how far I get.
And I would really,
really encourage
you to push me on all this,
because I am struggling my way
thinking through it.
So what I'm aiming
to do is to construct
what I see as a very urgently
needed conceptual framework
to understand contemporary
religious practice
in the margins of what
we consider technically
religion and ethical life.
In academe, I've tried to
bust my way into philosophy
departments, into religious
studies departments,
and India and
Hinduism-- there have
been questions about what
kind of religion is it.
Is it practice-based?
It's theologies.
And so it raises very
interesting questions
as to what is a religion
in the first place.
So this is the
neighborhood I studied.
It's in the north of the city.
It's called
Malleshwaram, but you
don't have to remember that.
And it was carved
out of virgin forest.
And as you can see on
the Google Maps page,
it's known for its temples.
The first thing that
pops up is the temples.
And so if you get
closer now, these
are the two temples I studied.
On Google Maps, they're within
quarter of a mile, half a mile,
of one another.
And the symbol for
a temple is the ohm.
So I began to study ritual
in two Hindu temples
in this neighborhood, and
I divided it carefully
between the two
large Hindu sects.
Vaishnavism, those who
worship Vishnu, and Shaivism,
those who worship Shiva.
So this is the Ganesha Temple
for those who worship Shiva,
and this is the deity.
And he's dressed in
tropical fruit on that day.
Guavas, pineapples
are all sliced,
and the image is
made out of fruit.
And somebody yesterday, when
I showed them this slide,
said, wow, think of the
number of fruit flies.
Yes, there are plenty of flies.
And Ganesha is the
elephant-faced god
who protects, and
then we have Vishnu
in the form of
the flute cowherd.
And he is the sort of
redemptive, blue-faced god.
So I decided to study
ritual in these two temples,
and I can hear you
think, why ritual?
And let me explain why.
Quite simply put, ritual is
the counterintuitive case
to creativity.
Let me explain that.
Ritual is always taught by
anthropologists and others
who study rituals to be
the antithesis of change.
It is where we go for tradition,
for stability, for continuity.
Gregory Bateson, Clifford
Geertz, Catherine Bell
have talked about
this repeatedly.
So any changes in
ritual-- any creativity,
I would argue-- have been
misdiagnosed as a disruption,
and I'm quoting, "a mistake, a
flaw, a distortion, an error,
or a failure."
So sites of creativity
that anthropologists
typically study--
and I'm not going
to go into all the
anthropologists,
but I'm looking at
South Asia particularly.
Anand Pandian studies cinema.
Kirin Narayan studies songs.
Tim Ingold doesn't study
South Asia, studies Britain,
but studies drawing
and painting.
And these are the classical
sides, artistic sides,
that we think of as
sites of creativity.
But I want to argue that
ritual is creative, too,
and this comes out
of my dissertation
defense at Harvard.
Because I started talking about
these disruptions and failures,
and a very famous professor,
who shall remain nameless,
said to me, but we know
these guys are creative.
That's nothing new.
And I thought, really?
I've never read that.
So then I thought, if we know we
it, why isn't it written down?
So I started thinking
about my own education.
And there's a famous essay by
a very famous anthropologist
Clifford Geertz.
A specialist audience will
know where I'm going with this,
but hey, I'll continue.
All anthropologists read
this in graduate school
if they don't read
it as an undergrad,
and it's about the funeral of
a young boy in Java, Indonesia.
I'm going to paraphrase
and bastardize,
but anyway, what happens is
this young boy dies unexpectedly
when he's living at
his uncle's house.
And his uncle happens to
have a new religious, secular
political identity.
The priest comes
over and says, well,
I can't do this funeral because
you are not a [? Bangan ?].
You're not of the
traditional type.
The uncle gets infuriated
and says, look,
this child has just died.
You need to do something.
So the entire village is thrown
into a moment of conflict.
And so Geertz talks about
this conflict, talks
about this funeral, and he
notes that funerals in Java
are meant to be, as he says,
"a languid letting go."
But here the residents show
"a froth of unusual emotion"--
I'm quoting-- "screaming and
crying, thinking and arguing,
sulking and storming away," and
meanwhile the body of the boy
simmers in the sunshine.
Geertz is focused on the fear
and confusion of the villagers.
The stalling and the
questioning pulls us back
into that concept of
social structure--
that rituals elevate us
to a movement, that is,
that defies social structure.
And then we are brought back
it into a social structure
in an enhanced, elevated state.
Well, one can, I argue, read
this text very differently,
because what happens
in the end of the story
is that, in point of fact,
the parents of the boy
traveled to the uncle's house
and they find a way out.
They actually improvise
something that works.
So why don't we read
it as a case study
of the initial
origin of creativity
rather than the
failure of ritual?
That would point to a
different direction.
So unlike contemporary
theorists,
who then begin with
social structure
and ask what ritual does--
its efficacy, its abilities,
its domestication of
strange forces, et cetera--
if we take Geertz's moment
as a moment of creativity,
we then ask what is a ritual.
Very different question.
And I want to ask
this simple question.
What is it?
How does it allow
for contingency?
How does it allow for a
radical revisionist reading?
How this vision uncoils
surreptitiously.
It draws together
modernity and religion.
And here I focus on a
very small snippet--
as I said, a snippet
of a snippet--
and I'm going to talk about
technology because technology
is, to many people,
enchanted in the first place.
I'm going to drag
you unfortunately--
I hope not kicking
and screaming--
through a little bit
of theory before I
get to the fascinating
stories I encountered.
So Jonathan C. Smith
suggests that ritual
is a particular mode
of paying attention.
It's a way of attending
more closely to our habitus,
and it is about the
doing of religion.
And let me show you three
slides in quick succession.
The first one was taken in 1999,
and it is the same procession
taken over 12 years.
So here the Lord
Krishna is taken out
in an evening procession-- the
scent of his jasmine garlands.
There's drumming and the white
umbrellas of sacred kingship.
This is six years later.
You can see electric
light has intruded.
You can see they're
doing it in the evening.
The god seems to
almost fade away
in the way the lights
are positioned.
And there's a video light.
That's what makes it so bright.
And this was in
2009, and you can
see that technology now changes
the devotee's relationship
to the god.
You collect pictures of the god.
They're on your phone, versus
the face to face version
that Diana Eck has talked
so beautifully about.
So if we think about it as
a mode of paying attention,
what does technology do to
this mode of paying attention?
Philip Fisher--
more beautifully,
Stephen Greenblatt-- tells us
that if we think about wonder,
it is visuality that
motivates us, the visual.
And that has an
enchantment all its own.
Here visual
experimentation consciously
opposes ritual creativity.
We'll get back to that.
And ritual creativity
here is a crucial means
of engaging contingency.
So improvisation becomes
a core around which
creativity is generated.
This was in Bangalore.
So Bangalore is very
big on creativity.
And as an aside,
when I was writing
this last week-- I was
writing this talk last week--
and I was in a hospital--
it had become clearer
why I was in this talk-- I
started watching the TV news.
And it's astounding how
frequently creativity, wonder,
curiosity keep repeating.
And I was watching the
news, so this was Viagra,
this was car
commercials, this was GE.
That's what they
were talking about.
So creativity is endemic,
as we understand it
in the modern world,
to new technologies
and new ways of being.
Now, it's not that
anthropologists have not
talked about wonder.
Margaret Mead, the
mother of anthropology,
talked about wonder
very early on.
And she says, "Anthropology
demands the open-mindedness
with which one must look and
listen, record in astonishment
and wonder at that
which one would not
have been able to guess."
So wonder for me is a
bewilderment at the engagement
of the Other, capital "O."
So it seems to me, well,
we don't hear of wonder
after Margaret Mead.
Anthropologists have been
strangely silent on wonder,
and my question was why.
So I think that an
ethnography of wonder
is both timely and urgent.
Why this urgency, you ask?
And let me simply
put it that when
we try to imagine new
worlds-- and I think
this will speak to what
the Radcliffe does-- when
we try to imagine new worlds and
we build upon them or we build
them, we open up creative
"what if" possibilities.
That is what we are
attempting to do,
and these "what if"s are the
center of all inquiry when we
dream of a world that
we cannot imagine today.
And it is the goal to
building new economies,
new technologies, new ways
of being, new resistances,
new imaginings, new
revolutions, et cetera.
And so we come back to Socrates,
where wisdom begins in wonder.
So there's a difference
here, of course,
between wonderment
and wondering,
and I'm playing with those two.
So the Oxford
English Dictionary--
I know I'm talking about the
Oxford English Dictionary
and you have one of
the templates here,
but I like the sort
of disturbance--
defines wonder as
"an emotion excited
by the perception of something
novel, something unexpected."
It extends to astonishment,
perplexity, bewilderment.
And in the Greek "thaumazein,"
the sudden descent of wonder
implies that you are passive
and you are wonder-struck,
struck by wonder.
But how passive are we?
An essential definition brings
to the forefront how little
we actually know about wonder.
We see it as a passive
condition that we receive.
It's extraordinariness,
it's suddenness,
it's seemingly divine
rupturing into the mundane.
So mundane is set in
opposition to wonderment.
In the 18th and 19th
centuries, if one
looks at the Western
intellectual history
of wonder-- Dunstan and Park
have done excellent work
on this, on science and how
wonder breeds curiosity.
It breeds collection,
as in the Wunderkammers,
and you get Galvani and Boyle,
the natural philosophers,
talking about everything
from the human body
to the crumbling
edges of the universe.
I know if Demetrius
were here, he
would say they
are not crumbling.
But it's a childlike amazement
that fuels us to ask.
And Philip Fisher
has said that wonder
is "a sudden experience of
an extraordinary object that
produces delight."
We'll hold that thought.
But I bring it into
the 20th century,
and I start looking
at who writes about
wonder in the 20th century.
And there is this
strange German scholar--
forgive me, Bob Orsi--
Rudolf Otto, who
writes this beautiful
book The Idea of the Holy,
Das Heilige, in which he
talks about the feeling
of the numinous.
And this feeling of the
numinous is essentially
a feeling of wonderment.
And I'm quoting Greg Alles who
has written this book on Otto.
For Alles, Otto's
numinous encompasses--
and I say it in alphabetical
order-- awe, bewilderment,
curiosity, confusion,
excitement, ecstasy, fear,
dread, marvel, mystery,
perplexity, reverence,
surprise, and supplication.
So it includes not only
the psychological effects
of receiving wonder, but,
as human beings perceive it,
of placing that wonder
squarely back on the Other
as the numinous of the divine.
So we feel it and we
ascribe it to divinity.
Strangely, the Upanishads
say the same thing,
and they were
2,500 years before.
By the way, I
couldn't resist this.
This is a decoration
made of American corn
two weeks ago for
the Ganesha Festival.
A chandelier of corn seemed
particularly wondrous
of American corn.
America has-- I won't use
the word dumped, but pushed
a lot of its corn,
as many of you know,
to different
economies, and this is
the way the priests
in Bangalore use it.
This is the essential Hindu
moment of looking at the god
and having the god look back
at you to recognize you.
Offering up the camphor flame,
the priest and his two sons.
And the devotion to the deity.
And this is me, and this
is my back doing fieldwork.
I am wondrous.
I'm wondering, and I'm
bewildered and I'm perplexed.
And I keep asking them
repeatedly questions.
And I liked it because
the priests are explaining
something to me, and there's
the processional guard
in the foreground
and the guard looking
at me from inside the alcove.
And this is the priest who
was a sort of philosopher,
an extempore philosopher.
He taught me everything
I know, and I told him
at the end of 15 years I
am so grateful that you
are the priest because
I could never be one.
And he said, yes,
you're a woman.
You couldn't be one anyway,
but if you were a man
you would have made
a very good priest.
I'll take that.
So to go back to my story, the
Upanishads 2,500 years ago talk
about wonder, and
they talk about
wonder in a fascinating way.
And I take this excerpt from
the Taittirya Upanishad,
which Kirin Narayan
brought to my notice.
And I've marked the words
that are important in red.
Haavu, haavu, haavu.
We have no essential
translation of this,
but it has been translated by
the mystical philosopher J.
Krishnamurti as "oh, wonderful,
oh, wonderful, oh, wonder."
Aham-annam-- "I am the food."
Aham-annam.
Annam-aham.
"I am the food, I am the food,
I am the eater of the food."
The story behind this is of
a saint who suddenly realizes
in a moment of
self-transformation the oneness
of the universe, and he realizes
he is not only the eater;
he is the food.
The tyranny and
beauty of universality
comes through to him.
And I put it up in Sanskrit
because the long r's
that are part of the
text are the [INAUDIBLE].
They are essentially
stating ecstasy.
He's in an ecstatic
moment of wonderment.
So wonder haunts this
text from 2,500 years ago,
and from this text we understand
it's a point of convergence.
He says, "suvarna
jyothi." "I am effulgent.
I am radiant with wonder."
It's a point of
convergence not only
of technologies of information,
of knowledge, self-knowledge
and other knowledge, but of
the soul-- so technologies
of information,
technologies of the soul.
Bear with me.
So back to the
temples in Bangalore
and to the first story, which I
called the "Animatronic Devi."
In October of every year, the
Hindu festival of Navratri,
of nine nights devoted
to the female principle,
occurs, and I'm quoting verbatim
from my field notes here.
And the female principle in
this particular nine nights
engages in a battle,
so it's basically
consciousness over ego,
the deity representing
consciousness and the
battle between the deity
and the demon.
The demon represents the ego.
The beautiful deity of
higher consciousness
is trying to defeat
Mahisha, the demonic ego.
He is aided by the
lesser demons of fear,
anger, greed, and lust, and
when he tries to grab her--
and you can see the sort of
demon with a buffalo head.
She's astride on a lion.
She's trying to draw her bow.
That's a more popular
representation of the demon.
This is a really
ancient sculpture.
So think of the rape of
Europa-- very similar.
So Mahisha tries to
grab the goddess,
and when he tries to capture
her she's instantly weaponized.
Fangs develop in
her howling mouth.
Her arms sprout
innumerable weapons--
the sword of discrimination,
the bow of determination,
the bludgeon of
psychic practice,
all with the ultimate nuclear
payload of powerful mantras.
She roars like the
lion she sits upon.
Don't mess with her.
So in October 1998--
there she is again--
Kashi, the head priest
of the Ganesha Temple,
told me of this Navratri myth.
In his telling,
the buffalo demon
is a master of disguise,
morphing instantly
from one form to
another, shapeshifting
as the ego is wont
to do, but the deity
recognizes him regardless
of what shape he takes.
She pours forth
millions of goddesses
from herself-- the goddess of
prudently applied intelligence,
the goddess of wisely
used materials sources.
And finally Parvathi,
the goddess of creation,
comes forth.
As she does so,
the goddess pierces
the demon's buffalo
head with a trident,
and she decapitates him.
Here Kashi got very excited.
He swung his arm to show
what the goddess does.
And he said he wanted
to do a decoration
of the deity, the female
deity, to show this power.
For a week before the
festival, Kashi mysteriously
walked on mechanical
apparatus, which
he kept covered with an oil
cloth in the lower courtyard.
I knew he had enlisted the help
of a couple of IT engineers
who came regularly
to the temple.
On days he looked tired,
defeated, and he told me,
"I have failed," in English,
as though he had taken an exam.
But he never said what
the Alankara would be.
Finally, the day for
the Pujah arrived.
Kashi disappeared into the
sanctum hidden by a curtain.
Several cutting,
mysterious sounds followed.
With a flourish, the
curtain was pulled back,
and the goddess was revealed.
She had one armed raised
in an alarming height,
and in it she clutched a
shining tinfoil trident.
At the goddess's feet was
a papier mâché buffalo with
a severed head
which ran red ink.
I want you to picture
the kitchiness of this.
As we watched the
spectacle transfixed,
light bulbs in the sanctum
flared and flashed,
and the right arm of
the deity came down
with a rolling cut like a garage
door, the trident striking
the buffalo's body.
Collectively the
assembled devotees
let out a long of "ah" of
astonishment and appreciation.
Their eyes were
wide open, and they
hissed-- the in-drawn hiss.
Suddenness.
They were wonderstruck.
For the next nine days, every
10 minutes, the deity's hand
would come down with the
sound of a garage door,
and every time I noticed that
the devotees were thrilled.
The children would applaud.
People would scream
with delight.
Michael Jackson,
also here at Harvard,
in his brilliant
phenomenological study
of the human tech interface,
talks about this interface
as having existential issues.
Human-machine
relations are where
our fate and destiny collide.
They are both implicated.
Indeed, in Bangalore, these
existential questions are rife,
but there are ethical and
theological questions as well.
I think that for a city
built on tech and innovation,
our reflection on the
connections between worship
and technology may
help us reframe
our most implicit taxonomies
of matter and spirit
into intellectually
freeing ways.
What is compelling
for me is the image
of the engagement, even
a union, between divinity
and technology.
It's not the typical
subject-object split
that we think of, but
an object-other split,
a cosmological split where the
material and the technological
become an apparatus
in creating belief.
A new, high-degree mode
of knowing is created.
So this reforging,
this resonance
of fusing the
deity and the robot
allows for chains of
equivalence to occur
of simultaneous existence
and annihilation,
changing not only the
meaning of the technology
but the biometrics
of the deity itself.
Here ritual, as Iliadi
noted, makes creation
again through an
ethos of improvisation
and experimentation.
Michael Puett-- I don't
know if he's here--
has written this
amazing set of texts
on ancient Chinese
ritual, and he
asked the central question,
how can we create anew?
And this question
I have followed
as the central sort of
mantra in attempting to parse
the other two examples.
So priests like Kashi engage
technological apparati
and the ethos of
newness as an instrument
and an agent of religious
change and transformation.
They allow an imagined
world full of potential,
full of creative
forces of possibility,
a propensity of life.
And he extends the divine
properties of both imagination
and creativity, marking
the devotee as an agent--
that wonder doesn't
just strike you,
but you strategically
seek wonder.
He creates the conditions in
which wonder is made possible.
So pursuit of wonder,
a practice of wonder,
becomes far more
important in this case.
And here when I asked him what
are you doing, quite simply he
said, "What I am doing?
What I am doing is technology,
yes, but what I am doing
is I am invoking Brahman,
the supreme deity."
Now, Brahman is this
cosmological deity from which
all things flow,
and he's referring
to the radical
meaning of Brahman.
In Sanskrit, root word
means "to grow, to expand."
The concept of
Brahman has wrongly
been imagined as a sort
of singular divinity,
but in point of fact, it is
about world impermanence.
It is the idea of the
continuity of change.
So ritual specialists like
Kashi play a double game.
They reference things that
we know very well which
may not in fact be really
new, but they put it
in a new context.
And in that new context, it
becomes the force of wonder.
And this is what Greenblatt
has talked about in resonance,
I think.
So Catherine Bell
says this resonance
is at the heart of ritual.
It is the domestication
of strange forces.
It makes the strange familiar,
the familiar strange.
Here lived experience
becomes blurred,
and the practice of wonder is,
I believe, about this blurring.
That is what elevates
you into a state
of worshipful astonishment.
I'm going to come
to Wittgenstein,
so those of you who are
thinking about Wittgenstein
hold the thought.
So in thinking about this,
another illustration is useful.
These are all the
devotees who came
to see the animatronic deity.
And it changes the
biometrics of divinity.
As you can see, here is
Ganesha taking a selfie
with his divine wife.
And here is the Ganesha deity
dressed as a software engineer.
You can see the lanyards.
This was first cool
around the time
of exams and entries
for engineering school,
medical school, et cetera.
The deity takes on this cast.
So the deity becomes
a familiar figure,
rather like Greek
and Roman deities--
a familiar,
human-like figure who
takes on the troubles
of our everyday,
but transcends
them all superbly.
The second illustration
might be useful.
So Kashi comes to
me, and he says
he wants to install a shrine
to this deity, the Devi deity.
And he wanted a
helicopter to shower
the temple, this new shrine,
with holy consecrated water
and rose petals for the
installation festival.
And he says the civil aviation
charges are around 60,000
rupees, then about $1,500.
He asked me, do you think
the prices are reasonable?
I point out I don't have
much experience with hiring
private helicopters.
It sounds reasonable to me.
The morning of the
consecration ceremony
I arrive at the Ganesha
Temple at 4:00 AM,
and I find Dando,
a neophyte priest,
giggling with excitement,
sporting a gigantic crash
helmet with a radio receiver.
One of the young priests slaps
him on the back and says,
[SPEAKING HINDI], well,
Top Gun, are you ready,
referencing the
popular Hollywood
movie starring Tom Cruise.
I saw Dando then depart on
a scooter with his friends,
flying to the helicopter
take-off site.
At 10:00 AM precisely, the
Mahabishekam, the consecration
part of the deity, where the
deity is given life, was over,
and the chanting of 108
priests reached a crescendo.
Suddenly, we heard
a buzzing sound.
The 108 priests stopped
dead and looked at the sky,
because we had all
heard there would
be a helicopter-- but nothing.
So we waited.
Suddenly, from behind
the temple tower,
rose the dark shadow of
the helicopter, rising
deliberately, almost
menacingly, like a scene
in an apocalyptic
Hollywood movie.
But as we watched, rising
also with the helicopter
was a lone Garuda, an
eagle, a brahminy kite,
the mythic vehicle of Vishnu.
The bird clearly
had been disturbed
from its nest in the
temple tree by the noise.
Kashi the priest became
incoherent in his excitement,
and forgetting the magnifying
effects of microphone
he shouted,
"Helicopter has come.
Helicopter.
Garuda is here.
Helicopter, Garuda, helicopter,
Garuda, Garuda, helicopter."
As some of the crowd of devotees
roared, "Garuda, helicopter,"
and folded their
hands in prayer,
Mr. Sambad, a retired engineer
at the Hindustan Aeronautics
Laboratory, where he had built
satellite communications,
repeated, "Garuda,
helicopter," and then
added "Vishnu's vehicle"
as the helicopter
hovered in the clear blue sky.
We were all drenched in
red and yellow petals
and consecrated holy water as
Dando was peering anxiously
over the edge of the helicopter
and finally found his mark.
Many of the devotees were moved
and had tears streaming down
their faces.
I was embarrassed
to say I did, too.
Mr. Sambad and his
friend Mr. [? Ayers ?]
said, [INAUDIBLE], that
it is a wonderful site.
I found myself moved
to tears as well.
Now, one might argue
that such improvisation,
the use of non-new
technologies in new contexts,
is sort of practicality
attendant to piety.
That's what Michael Herzfeld
has so persuasively argued,
and he argued this
just last year
and I was so taken with it.
But I want to suggest
that something more is
happening here.
When I looked at my
notes over 16 years,
I found the word "wonderment,"
or its cognates, 2,000 times.
So something else
is happening, and it
forces us to take note not
only what the priests are
doing seriously but what they
say they are doing seriously as
well.
And in subsequent
days and even years,
I heard devotees talk
about the ceremony
as "helicopter aputa," the
astonishment of the helicopter.
Aputa, loosely translated,
means "odd" in Sanskrit,
but it also is wonder,
astonishment, and awe.
So what Kashi was
doing was he was
creating a hybrid
between the technological
and the marvelous, a
conjoined material one,
an imagined mythic
bird that spoke
of both newer technology--
newish technologies--
and ancient myth.
It was the sudden conflation,
this mythic disorientation,
that was aputa.
It is a sublime
vision that conjoins
reason and passion,
which have been separated
in Western understandings.
And it puts us in a contingent
state that is highly valuable.
It's an excited
contingent state.
Helicopters become valued
not only as status symbols,
but as representing
divine transport.
So one part of my
thinking in this book
is going to be about
tedium and mundanity
and how wonder breaks through
tedium and re-crafts things.
Now, of course, one
could and should
argue that not every time
that the helicopter appears
does the Garuda appear.
It was essentially
an act of God.
It's unpredictable.
The intersection was marvelous.
But Kashi said that he was
purposely using the helicopter
to create a moment when
wonderment might make
its appearance, so again
the pursuit of wonderment
versus its actual application.
And for believers
perhaps this is wondrous.
Wonder is the creation of
this sublime aesthetic moment
both as a new
category of experience
and as a subversion of
previously understood texts--
previously understood
relationships and texts.
So Puett tells us
that these wonder
and, well, ritual
that is created
pushes us towards a
subjunctive state, and I agree.
So practices of wonder
push us to consider
the future and
futurities and how
we imagine these futurities.
This potentiality, this world
as pregnant in becoming,
is a key to understanding
the durability of ritual.
This is why ritual makes sense.
This is what ritual is.
It gives us the fuel
to imagine possibility
in a world that is
constantly engaging the new,
from making anew, renewing,
and encountering the new.
So it folds all that
together and creates
possibilities and imaginations
of the future, the possibility
to imagine the future.
This, I believe, is what
Bergson calls the "élan vital,"
or the propulsive
life towards a future.
Michael Fisher, down
the road at MIT,
says technology marks a
kind of messianic space,
and I think that this is
exactly what Kashi is doing.
And he's using it as a
heightened experimental regime.
Now, I know for the scientists
here experimentation
would imply failure, and
in the rest of the book
I do have mixed examples
of when the wonder fails--
pursuit of wonder
fails spectacularly
and it becomes just mundane.
And so there is a sort
of pushing and trying
newer and newer things.
So the larger acceptance
of what is improvisational
marks the temple
space as a space
of constant experimentation.
This experimental
regime, combined
with the idea that the
public imagination,
the Hindu imagination-- Hinduism
is the dominant religion--
it's complex, but
it's also provisional.
So residents can be
taken by emotions,
but they can also
imagine a future.
They can incorporate
helicopters,
new forms of money like
credit cards, into the temple
and into their lives
without feeling the anxiety
of leaving something behind.
So rather than the
disenchantment of modernity,
which Peter Berger
has talked about
and people after
him have worked on,
I would argue that
this form of modernity
doubles down on enchantment.
And now, it has become
everyday wonderment.
And to my last example,
wonderment came to my life
most vividly a week ago.
My mother needed
a pacemaker, and I
called Kashi-- and this was my
first time I actually used him
as a priest-- to do
a personal worship
puta for her well-being.
He recommended a
Vedic fire sacrifice
that was [INAUDIBLE],
a defeat of death.
As we went through
the details of my vow
and my mother's lineage descent
on the astrological chart,
which is what he needed,
Kashi asked me an aside.
He suddenly said, do you have
Macbook Skype in English.
And I said, no.
He said FaceTime, FaceTime?
I said, yes.
Then he says, OK, live relay--
all in English, by the way.
Then he switches to Tamil.
"Your mother can see the Pujah.
I'll give you a missed call."
This is a salutation thing
of where he calls you
and then he doesn't
pay for the call,
and then you see the number
and then you call him back.
Missed call.
So traditionally,
darshan is when
you are face to face
with a god, as I said.
You see the god,
the god sees you.
The camphor flame
moves between the two.
So this is classic--
people waiting
for darshan in the temple.
This is darshan,
everyone leaning in
to see the god at
the moment when
the camphor flame is offered.
And more importantly,
the god looks at you,
so now we get to this.
"Your mother can get darshan."
The next evening we
facetime Kashi on his iPhone
after his missed call prompt
at the auspicious start
time of the ritual.
Over FaceTime he showed us
the entire scene in Bangalore.
The monsoon rains had left
the temple courtyard wet.
The sun just had risen
behind the ficus tree
where we had seen the Garuda,
and the choir of birds
were whooping and whistling
in the branches above.
He began the Sankalpa, the
slow unfurling of ritual intent
with the instructions in English
"repeat after me" to my mother.
Kashi recited the Sanskrit
slokas and mantras,
and my mother, seated on a
sofa in the Boston night,
repeated them.
We watched late into
the night as priests
recited the sacred mantras,
the rites of gods and plants,
the invocation of planetary gods
into their lives, their ritual
adoration and sacrifice.
We watched as Kashi and
his cohort of priests
laid the Vedic fire,
ringed it with grass,
and offered it sacrifices for
my mother's life and health.
I have a video, which is
going to be quite loud,
but I think you can see
the Vedic fire here.
[CHANTING]
So this is a very
ancient ritual,
and you would have heard
the word Rukmini, which
is my mother's name.
And he's essentially
battling death on her behalf.
And then he finishes
that, and then he
offers us the camphor flame.
Watch this.
He builds it to a form.
And my mother takes darshan.
So this is 10,600 miles away.
Occasionally, during
the ritual, the internet
would cut out, the
signals dying as they
pass through fiber optic cables
deep under the ocean floor.
Kashi would disappear while
that slowly spinning circle
rebuffered.
But soon he would reappear
stronger than ever and say,
network OK?
Then once when the Vedic
sacrificial fire flickered low,
he gestured to it and
said jokingly in Tamil,
"Our network is going down.
The network of Agni
needs more key,"
indicating that
his network was one
made of smoke that carried
the sacrifices to the gods,
just as our network that linked
us was a virtual one as well.
In one reconnect, I
happened to place my iPhone,
and if we go back maybe
you can see the scene.
Behind my phone
is the deity I had
placed for my mother to view.
So in one reconnect, I happened
to place my iPhone in front
of a brightly
colored Ganesha image
I had placed on my
table in Boston.
As the form reconnected,
for that instant
we saw Kashi's puzzled
face as he looked directly
at the face of the god just
before he went to life.
He came in chuckling, "oh,
look, my boss is now in America.
Super, super."
He referred to this
network repeatedly,
and when I reminded him of
what he said about Brahman
he said, exactly.
That is what I meant.
So essentially, I was
left with this question.
It's wonderful and
amusing and it draws you
in, but what are the ethics
of this kind of hack?
What is actually happening here?
What are the morals
of improvisation?
Because I think we
all laud creativity.
It's important.
We all want to be leaders.
Every university
tells us that they
want to train us in creativity.
What does that mean?
In South Asia, Pandian and Ali
have considered ethical life,
and they say the ethical
choices are indelibly
conjoined with the problems of
mundane living in South Asia.
But it would appear to
me that people like Kashi
and the pursuit of
wonder that they do
have some unforeseen outcomes.
But such injunctions
are routinely
broken or transcended, and
morals are continuously eroded.
So creative ethics
is each point along
this unpredictable trajectory.
So I came up with this.
I don't like the
term creative ethics,
and I seek a better
term from you all.
But that's the best
I could come up with.
It's each point
along this trajectory
as a sediment of
repeated actions that
are special to devotees
and priests themselves
are performed, and they shift
ever so slightly over time.
They create a language,
volatility of growth,
and a shift in the
ethical paradigm
that is almost untraceable.
It happens, but one
is not cognizant of it
happening at the moment
that it's happening.
The creative ethical
paradigm is thus
constantly shifting,
refining, and extending
to reach a final form.
I don't know if
I should do this,
but very quickly,
Dharma is a word
that's used in Hindu
philosophy repeatedly.
And it is used as a sort
of rigid call to duty.
Dharma is translated as duty.
But here it becomes a
fluid ethical analytic
that the devotees and priests
use very differentially.
It becomes a space
of vulnerability
where duty is ceded, duty's
use might not even be dutiful.
So they are translating
in a very loose way.
So perhaps the good life is
not so good or not so moral
after all.
Untangling unethical
and ethical becomes
very difficult at the
moment of improvisation.
Creativity can be
rooted in violence,
we know, in
disruption, in failure
of that which is
familiar and stable,
and it results in
inevitable moral dilemmas
that are unresolvable.
But it allows us to
approach a limit condition
to create new imaginations.
We open up the world of creative
formulations and reformations,
allowing for experiences
that are alive, creative,
life-affirming, radical,
and perhaps even freeing.
In conclusion, I
confess I've been
struggling how to write this.
You see, it's not easy.
Wonder is such an
evanescent condition.
I think I will write as an
experimental folio where
this sense of creative
play and interrogation
and the joy that the priests
have should come out,
I believe, rather than
a textual treatise that
moves us towards closure.
So I think the fragments
of creative acts
that I present give
us some sense of what
is going on in Bangalore.
I take heart in Rainer
Maria Rilke's statement
that most questions are
unanswerable when asked.
One has to live out the answers.
In keeping with that
modality, I write what I know,
but I try to write through
to what I don't know.
And I invite openings
in the joints
between wonder and creativity,
for, after all, Fredrik Barth
said one thing with
regard to anthropologists.
He said studying change
is urgent and central
to the anthropological endeavor.
We need new concepts that allow
us to observe and describe
events of change.
So we have understood
change only as disruption,
and I have focused
on this disruption.
But in these spaces,
in these interruptions,
priests like Kashi not only
are informed by the zeitgeist.
They push it forward and inform
the categories of universal
in particular in
very specific ways,
and they make us think
about universal, particular,
contemporary, comparative--
these structures
that are very foundational to
interrogations of knowledge.
Thank you.